this video is sponsored by ridge wallet
[Applause]
[Music]
say the line mark
this is the best arc of the post time
skip material
i'm calling it now and i'm not even
finished yet this is a
delicious ark satisfying sweet but not
too sweet
this week i covered a decent chunk of
whole cake island and i really
am excited to discuss what might be my
new favorite arc in this series and let
me tell you
this thing gets emotional so much crazy
stuff happens in this story and again
let me remind you it's not even close to
being done yet but perhaps what's more
is that it's the first part of one
piece's post-time skip material
to make these shed a tear again that's
right the tears are back and i plan on
discussing that today
because no matter how many false
copyright claims tony animation sends my
way
i'm totally not mark and these are my
first impressions of thoughts on and
review for
the sweet bitter and fulfilling first
part
to whole cake
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is a beautiful arc as i mentioned
before
possibly the single most emotionally
resonant of the series
and for those of you that are familiar
with it you'll know that's a pretty big
claim considering the big arc contenders
for that title in this series
one piece has in its catalogue some
fantastic action and storytelling yes
but the cornerstones to perhaps most of
its tales is some sort of
emotional through line immediately what
came to mind for me were stories like
arlong park with nami
water seven in indy's lobby with usopp
and robin or even marine ford with ace
all of these are tremendous stories that
have an emotionally driven narrative
focusing on characters we care about in
one way or another
exploring their darker secrets and
putting them into extreme circumstances
to see how they navigate them and that
is so interesting one piece has a litany
of incredibly interesting secondary and
tertiary characters but
by far and away i think we can all agree
the most interesting characters in this
series are the straw hat crew and when
we get individual story arcs concerning
these guys specifically
it makes for what i think personally are
the most interesting one piece arcs
and yet whole cake island has affected
me the most dealing with the character
of sanji primarily this arc explores his
past
explains how and why he thinks the way
that he does and investigates the
relationships of his past
and contrasts them beautifully with
those of his present dealing with themes
of hatred
bullying betrayal and love during whole
cake island we observe one of the
original straw hats
more emotionally vulnerable and broken
down by unfair circumstances than we
ever have in the past
at numerous points during the story i
felt despair nostalgia and even a
significant amount of discomfort with
some of the scenes that were shown
in this first half this is a spectacular
arc and like the others i've reviewed i
will split this up into three sections
to make my life a little easier
so let's dive right into part one the
point of view
during this opening section of the story
there are two primary points of view
that are given the most focus
these are the point of view of luffy
with his crew and the point of view of
the now expected to be married
sanji the third son of the vinsmoke
family which is honestly sort of cute
because the sun in sanji is the japanese
word for the number three
speaking of his other brothers i mention
sanji was the third son in the vinsmoke
family which means he has three other
brothers
all of them are just who really bad
people the first of these three brothers
were introduced to
is that of yachtsme through the point of
view of the straw hat's venturing
towards whole cake island i really
enjoyed this particular interaction
because it gave us the chance to see
what sort of fellow he was
instead of telling us luffy is in this
case poisoned after eating the skin of a
very poisonous fish
and is given an option help or not to
help
and he chose not to immediately helping
us identify him as a
hashtag scumbag thankfully however all
of the vinsmoke children aren't
heartless bystanders and in this scene
we are also introduced to the character
of reiju sanji's
older sister as she sucks the poison out
of luffy successfully restoring him back
to normal
while i didn't think this scene was
particularly deep it'd at least serve to
effectively introduce us to two
characters that would be playing pivotal
roles in this story and gives us insight
into how they act and behave
one aspect of this story however that i
loved is how it effectively keeps you
off balance
characters we would normally believe to
be dangerous aren't really and
characters we believe
not to be kind totally are but i think
the living embodiment of this unstable
element within this story is pudding the
soon-to-be wife of sanji she is
unbelievably kind understanding in this
story going as far as to explain to
luffy that she won't marry sanji if
he doesn't want to now at this point in
the story i was wondering personally
uh where'd the conflict at because i'm
not seeing much of any conflict anywhere
she is way too reasonable we don't have
a major enemy besides big mom who hasn't
necessarily done anything to sanji yet
but there's this very subtle sense that
all isn't as it seems on this island so
what's going on well pudding tells them
that she will meet them at the secret
part of whole cake island
but when the straw hats return to their
ship carved into the wall are the words
turn back and peacoms is missing there's
our conflict and some mystery to boot
what happened to b comes and did he
write that on the wall
to be honest i was surprised it took
this long for conflict to arise and in
such a subtle and foreboding way also
we are after all on the island that acts
as the home base for one of the emperors
of the sea in big mom
going into this i was expecting her to
be way more dangerous
big mom is terrifying in the truest
sense of the word and to be clear
looking at what she's capable of here i
have no idea how luffy and the others
once they do eventually collide with her
how they will possibly overcome what she
brings to the table
she can steal the lifespan of those that
get in her way
with this mechanic being introduced to
us by way of her inflicting this upon
her
own son which again serves to throw me
off balance a self-proclaimed mother
doing something so horrible to her own
children
it's unsettling made all the more creepy
by how upbeat and sugar-coated
everything in her surrounding areas are
this island and those surrounding it
have a big secret beneath the sweet
exterior is a rotten core
made all the more abundantly clear when
jinbe reveals he has been part of big
mom's forces but also announces that he
wants out
bringing full circle the plot thread
from fishman island where jinbe had to
deny luffy's recruitment simply because
he had stuff he needed to deal with and
it turns out this was that very business
but it's not as simple as that
unfortunately and in order to leave big
mom
brings out this roulette wheel and they
leave it on a cliffhanger what
anyways we go back to the straw head
ship with luffy and co as they decide to
split up into two teams luffy nami
chopper and carrot head to the part of
whole cake island the pudding said that
she would meet them and the second team
pedro and brooke
decided to covertly see if they could
retrieve the prince from the podoglyphs
in big mom's possession there's a lot
going on and this is when things
really start to get interesting you
might have noticed that i have refrained
from talking about sanji specifically
and that's because
i want to dedicate an appropriate amount
of time too without fracturing it
throughout this review so let's discuss
sanji's point of view within this story
and the tragic circumstances that befall
him therein
as mentioned earlier in this review
sanji has three other brothers
as well as a sister of them we have met
reiju his merciful sister and
his unsympathetic and mean-spirited
brother which leaves two brothers
unaccounted for however in the same
fashion the other two had a scene that
demonstrated their characters briefly
so too do ichiji and niji sanji's two
older brothers
spoiled filled with self-importance and
even going as far as to demand his
people to act as meat shields
in the heat of battle it's horrific and
gruesomely communicates these two to us
in a succinct manner these are sanji's
two
older brothers and they mean business
and now that we've met all of his
siblings i guess now's as good a time as
any to meet daddy
this is sanji's father his name is judge
and he is the
absolute worst most dogmatic tyrannical
version of the father figure we've yet
seen in this story through this tense
but illuminating scene between him and
sanji meeting again for the very first
time in decades it's brought to our
attention what might have been the
motivating factors behind sanji fleeing
his home in the first place but moreover
we see through the thin veil of this
weak man as he demonstrates his
obsession with bringing the vinsmoke
name back to his former prestige by
ruling over all of the north blue once
again
and to do that he decides the best
course of action was to use his children
sanji being the only one among them he
labels as a failure for reasons that are
yet unknown to us
and just in case you thought this wasn't
interesting a fight between sanji and
his father comes to fruition
it's sanji versus his father yes
i'll have some of that please now this
isn't super long or anything but what it
achieves in the story within the short
amount of time it demands our attention
is nothing to scoff at it's clear that
this encounter is there also to
explicitly reveal in part the sort of
upbringing sanjay had to endure but also
to teach us about the type of individual
who would inflict the child with this
sort of zero tolerance policy
sprinkled throughout this fantastic
scene are glimpses into sanji's
childhood
there we see his brother's torture
ridicule and belittle him
and his interests with his father even
labeling him as the shame of the family
what a horrible thing to say to anyone
let alone your own son but the best part
of this scene in my opinion comes in how
the fight itself is structured and
designed
this isn't like any ordinary fight in
this series there's no prestige there's
no build up
this fight is here to show us exactly
what sort of person judge is and why
sanji is different highlighted early on
is judges surprised by how capable sanji
is as a warrior
even remarking over his use of haki but
quickly judged to the use of his
disgusting tactics like
human walls and blatant disregard for
life overcome sanji who is unwilling to
participate in such barbarism this fight
then concludes with judge having won
but sanji having stayed true to who he
is it's a phenomenal scene that serves
to highlight perhaps what is the point
of contention between sanji and his
family
his empathy and his kindness and if that
fight wasn't indicative of the sort
judge is
in true scumbag fashion fearing that his
son won't comply with his demands and
marry pudding he straps two bracelets
onto the wrists of
sanji the same sort of braces the
celestial dragons used for their slaves
and so if sanji doesn't go through with
this marriage and make his family
stronger by association to big mom
they will blow up his hands and the
worst part
big mom holds the key these scenes for
sanji paint for us a very clear picture
sanji is a prisoner within his own
family ridiculed and abused by his
brothers and father
and to be honest seeing the abuse this
poor man endured in these scenes and the
hints to what he went through during
childhood his only option right now
seems to be marriage to pudding even if
that's a tough pill to swallow although
she does seem to be more kind-hearted
than we or
certainly i envisioned given what's
going on all around her and that's sort
of what i meant when i said that this
story keeps me off balance
and believe you me this arc still has
one of the most emotionally intense
scenes still to come
heck there are two really emotional
scenes still coming but first we gotta
finish off what luffy's been up to
before we can go to that and this part
here is perhaps the best fight
in the arc i'll be reviewing in this
video and easily the best portion from
the creepy forest section for luffy
you're pointing at me right now as you
say that
okay jokes aside this wasn't the best
fight but it was funny as hell when i
was reading through it watching luffy
struggle to figure out what in the name
of god
is happening to him right now is
hilariously funny but that's not all we
learn about this for us putting told us
to head for
you see we learned that this forest is
alive
and the entity lurking inside of it is
none other than a daughter and son of
big mom
in brulee and cracker oh okay yeah
while brulee is bad news locking chopper
and carried away in a mirror dimension
i'll get to that later this cracker guy
is what causes the bulk of the issues
for the straw hats in these woods
or more specifically luffy this guy is
an absolute bruiser boasting a bounty of
840 million berries it's clear to see
just by how easily he brushes off gear 3
how impossibly powerful he really is and
what's more interesting
is what happens when luffy uses gear 4.
personally i love this fight not because
it's the best i've seen from the series
or anything like that but because of how
well it serves the story it's a part of
existing within a largely emotional
story filled with serious intense
encounters left and right these scenes
offer us while still being cool as all
heck
a much needed break to the tension with
some levity that i really enjoyed an
easy highlight for me being when we
realized that luffy has been fighting
this cracker man for 11 straight
hours in an effort to get to sanji this
is specifically funny because his soul
strategy seems to
be eating his attacks with whomever
loses the will to go on
being the loser it's stupidly effective
in terms of whipping up some interesting
action set pieces some light-hearted
comedy all the while demonstrating to us
that luffy is willing to risk his life
to rescue sanji from this island's
clutches
and while he does eventually overcome
this massive enemy cracker
sending him flying with a creative
combination of his uniquely bloated form
in tandem with the gear 4 ability
afterwards it poses the very real issue
of having luffy extremely fatigued
lying asleep as they exit the forest oh
and
uh i almost forgot there's also this
scene in the woods where luffy fought
cracker where nami realizes that she has
this vivre paper from way back in
thriller park
this paper was pointing to the mother of
lola who happens to be
big mom like okay what this happened
like hundreds and hundreds of chapters
ago
oda you absolute monument to human
patience
now time to get to the good stuff
[Music]
this video is brought to you by ridge
wallet most people are still using
wallets designed in the 1990s and
in this modern landscape it's seriously
outdated and i should know i've been
using the same wallet since i was 15
years old and that means i've been using
some outdated wallet for the last 14
years of my life
in the same way phones have gotten more
practical and compact over the last few
decades so too
have wallets and it's honestly made a
massive difference to my pockets
personally i hate having cumbersome
items in there and this totally fits my
new lifestyle it holds up to 12
separate cards plus room for cash and
there's over 30 different colors and
styles including carbon fiber and burnt
titanium to choose from
and if that wasn't enough to win you
over yet check out their 30
000 5 star reviews the durable nature of
each of these wallets comes with a
lifetime warranty so
in theory you could buy this one wallet
and carry it for life and the rich team
have told me that they're so
confident that you like it that they'll
actually let you test drive it for 45
days
that means you can send it back for a
full refund if it's not up to your own
standards
right now there's a special offer going
where you can get 10 off with
free worldwide shipping and returns and
you can get all of this by going to
ridge.com
not mark and using the coupon code not
mark at checkout
link is in the description hey have you
ever heard about the great blue
oh oh it's awesome
this scene here is one of the best
scenes that this arc has to offer and i
think it says a lot about me as a reader
for liking it this much it's just a
bunch of people conflicting around the
dinner table
it's simple it's dramatic and it
highlights exactly where the differences
between sanji and his family lie
having just arrived home from their time
spent in another war effort this is the
first time we see all four brothers
together as
adults ichiji niji sanji and this scene
takes two aspects that are integral to
sanji's character
and forces him to undergo difficult
circumstances to remain true to himself
firstly by insisting that his brother
finishes his food to which his brother
doesn't like to be spoken that way too
by someone he sees as vastly inferior
and secondly when the female chef is
called to be reprimanded for the
terrible meal she's made
sanji not only represents his family for
being so ungrateful and superior to
their fellow man but also
eats the food that was dropped on the
floor and told the chef
he thought it was delicious that's such
a wonderful thing for sanji to do
and honestly perfectly encapsulates his
character's ideals in this scene
but unfortunately later sanji finds the
chef beaten to within an inch of her
life with them citing that she had to
know her place after sanji
stood up for her this scene was
spectacular highlighting exactly what i
love about sanji giving me more reasons
to despise his brothers and father while
also highlighting what exactly he did
as a child to through flashbacks these
four young brothers were intended on
being born special with sanji being the
clear runt of the group
falling behind in almost every task and
challenge asked of him
and showing interest in things they see
as beneath them leading to his father
demanding that he be locked away in a
cell beneath his property
wearing a helmet these horrific acts of
torture led sanji with the help of his
sister to run away from this tormented
life
and it's honestly harrowing to read
through
visually these scenes communicate so
much to us also everything about sanji
is different from his brothers from his
expression the clothes he wears and even
how his hair is understated like his
mother's
when the rest have extravagant stylings
to exude their greater than thou
personalities
sanji is so different to his family even
his eyebrows curl in the opposite
direction and what's more is that now
zeph's very life is being threatened if
he doesn't go through with this wedding
also he is trapped in a horrible
set of circumstances that keep mounting
higher and higher against him by the
time this scene ends
with how these vinsmokes are threatening
sanji's only father figure with how they
abuse sanji as the child and with how
they left that poor chef beaten in a
bloodied heap on the floor i now desire
sanji or luffy or both to bring balance
to this world again to take out the
tyrants that tore him down for who he
was and to reunite with the family that
he loves
for those same reasons stakes have never
been higher for sanji he is faced with a
massive conflict in his mind and now
another conflict comes running over the
hill that he wasn't expecting to have to
deal with
in the second section of this video
damage and conflict
[Applause]
in this section we explore all the setup
with each character respectively and
watch as they clash and conflict through
either misunderstanding or tragedy the
first coming in the form of this
initially charming interaction
and i love luffy he's one of the most
well realized characters i've ever had
the pleasure of watching traverse a
world
every scene he participates in serves to
inform us of his character he never
wants to be disrespectful or to treat
anyone in any mean-spirited way
intentionally his default is to always
treat others as he would like to be
treated overly friendly and enthusiastic
eager to gain friendship and so despite
having been on the receiving end
of an army of cracker men his face
lights up when he finally sees sanji
again
leaping onto his family's carriage much
to the surprise and chagrin
of sanji and his family and this was
where i realized what was going to
happen
luffy doesn't know everything that sanji
has to lose if he doesn't go through
with this wedding and
thus
[Music]
this is a heartbreaking scene simply
because of the characters participating
within it firstly i think it's safe to
say that there's a tremendous connection
we all felt towards these characters and
that's thanks to the fantastically and
phenomenally well-placed character
writing in general in this series
but what's more is that these harsh
words sanji spouts act and towards luffy
made me reflect on this series with two
characters that have been
on this journey for well over 750
chapters
and watching them fight here in this
wasn't easy to watch at all
sanji landed attack after attack
essentially trying to ensure the lives
of his friends
by doing what might be the hardest
things he's ever had to do in his life
knocking out his own captain and best
friend betraying them
and returning to his carriage after
blustering towards them a number
of lies and as the carriage rolls away
sanji just
breaks down unable to stop the stream of
tears cascading down his face
this chapter 844 is the best chapter of
one piece
i've read through since luffy versus
usopp and i'm not saying that lightly
luffy is refusing to fight sanji's
insistence on pushing his friends away
for their own protection
and all the conflicting interesting
motivations at play here while the
vinsmokes watch from afar
make for an intensely interesting set of
circumstances that had me glued to every
page
[Music]
looking at the usop and luffy section
where they were brutally honest with one
another they have this scene here that
is held together by sanji being brutally
dishonest for the sake of his captain
and friends
it's a masterpiece and i absolutely
adore it
and if that wasn't enough luffy declares
as sanji rides off to his gathering with
big mom he won't eat
any food unless it's prepared by him and
he won't move from this spot
until he comes back meanwhile an army of
big mom's forces begin riding across the
hillside
towards them nami is scared luffy
is exhausted what a story now the rest
of this section has some really
interesting cute interactions between
sanji and pudding some deeply upsetting
ones between nami and a broken luffy as
he's dragged off into a cell
and a great collection of scenes dealing
with pedro and brooke as they move about
the island of whole cake being the only
ones left from the original party not
having been found yet
i don't really have much to say about
this bee plot other than that it serves
its purpose relatively well in spitting
up the action and informing us of the
whereabouts of the certain key
characters and where their hearts lie
another b plot that i thought was worth
mentioning is that of chopper and carrot
the two furry mascots of one piece get
to enjoy their own little story in this
mirror world
as they escape the forces of brulee
reprimand her and use that dimension to
their advantage in a really creative way
of popping to and from different mirrors
all across the island and since they
already have their hands on brulee now
it's
sort of like a wormhole to anywhere they
want to go on the island
in retrospect that was a bad hostage for
them to gain control of for big mom
however all of that b plot comedy aside
we are still faced with the grim reality
having befallen luffy and nami
but thankfully pudding is here and
perhaps you can alleviate some pressures
and stresses
from them with some reassuring words
[Music]
the way this pudding character is
utilized in the story is honestly
really well done now i was never 100
convinced she was as amazing as she
seems to have been but whenever it comes
to any interaction we see her
participate
in she never seems to miss a beat she
comes across as natural
and kind which as i've mentioned threw
myself as a reader off balance quite a
few times while i was reading through
this part of the story and it's that
very aspect of her character that made
her so compelling
in this scene with luffy prior to it
luffy is deflated and miserable but
after hearing what pudding whispered
into his ear he suddenly became
filled with purpose preparing to rip his
arms from the wall
what did she say to him again looking
back now what i know it's clear what she
said but in the moment given everything
she's contributed to
this part of the story it was still sort
of a coin toss as to whether or not
she's motivating luffy in a positive way
or a negative one
point being it wasn't obvious which made
this pivotal scene
following it with sanji all the more
fascinating shocking
and heartbreakingly tragic in this arc
this story with sanji that's been
explained to us shown to us
and that we've experienced firsthand
reads like a tragedy
sanji simply wants something that's
reasonable companionship and freedom but
through a gauntlet of vicious and
merciless circumstances he is
essentially held prisoner by his family
and not to mention the forces of big mom
with his father figure zeph being
threatened with his life his hands
primed to be blown to smithereens and
the attacking of his very own captain
luffy
sanji is very much a man lost in a
turbulency of tragic circumstance but he
does have a lifesaver a light
in this dark situation and that's
pudding someone who has shown genuine
affection for him and honestly the only
person who's
even shown him at minutia of sympathy
and empathy throughout this entire
ordeal and so
sanji having accepted his situation as
unavoidable and uncompromising he
accepts his current predicament
and walks to puddin's room with a
freshly made array of foods
prepared specifically for her to share
with but at the door he stopped from
entering her chambers
with the door itself citing that she's
otherwise preoccupied right now
and as a quick aside something i thought
that was worth mentioning for the sake
of me being intellectually consistent
with the sanji character
when faced with this blockade at the
door he elects to try to climb through
her window
in a romantic fashion obviously this
gesture and the setting is very
shakespearean and romantic but what i
personally found rather nice about sanji
in this moment was his consideration for
the consequences of him climbing up in
to see her
specifically citing in a particular
panel that it could be construed as
peeping
and therefore that would be a reason not
to do it now eventually he does
reconcile this with the fact that she's
his fiancee and that they will soon be
husband and wife but it's really nice to
see sanji consider those as factors that
would prevent him from doing it it puts
them into a much more reasonable and
kinder light than that which was on
display during thriller bark
and i'm honestly thrilled about that
fact but what makes this scene all the
more effective in the manga is how at
regular intervals throughout sanji
making his way to the window of pudding
spliced in are shots of luffy attempting
to rip off his arms in an effort to get
free
he knows something that we don't
motivated by pudding's last words to him
coupled with sanji making his way slowly
to her window
make for an incredibly tense build-up to
the ultimate reveal of this arc thus far
[Music]
the power behind this scene for me never
came from the reveal itself because
as i mentioned it was sort of difficult
not to see something big coming from
pudding and this sort of fits that
narrative perfectly the power for this
scene instead came from sanji's reaction
to this news
as pudding describes her insidious plan
to kill sanji and the rest of his family
before they marry
we are met with shot after shot after
shot of sanji as he tries to put on the
brave face he has for this entire ordeal
before crumbling
and breaking down as pudding's voice
echoes in the background continuing to
ridicule him to his sister for how he
proposed to her
reinforcing the same sort of bullying
that he endured from his brothers
his one and only salvation during this
horrible circumstance betrays his good
nature like so many have already taken
advantage of in the past
calling him a failure a pathetic excuse
for a groom
and not a proper prince this scene made
me tear up like few other stories from
one piece have done in the past
it's an extremely relatable situation to
overhear something you weren't meant to
hear about yourself
made all the more effective by the
gloomy weather making even lighting his
cigarette
all the more difficult much like
everything else in his life right now he
has lost control he can't even
light his cigarette i love this scene
with it we now
understand sanji luffy and pudding as
well as her powers
which are ridiculously powerful she has
the ability to edit
memories essentially which again like
the sugar power from dressrosa these
mind-altering abilities have the
potential to be incredibly powerful if
used correctly so i'm interested to see
how her powers play out in the rest of
the story when i do eventually get to it
this is the turning point of the story
this instance where for the first time
in a long time the pendulum of fortune
swings in the favor of the straw hats
and after being at such a depth of
despair
just moments prior the sudden and
surprising revelation of jinbe was
so welcome let me tell you so much so i
jumped out of my chair and was like
hell yeah it's at this point of
salvation jinbe saves luffy and on his
way to find sanji in order to warn him
too
reiju lets luffy know that sanji is up
to speed and knows everything
with that luffy relaxes before leaping
out of what looks like to be a very high
window did i mention i love luffy
i just love stuff like that it's just so
fun i mean after all he did promise he
would wait in a specific spot but
in saying that at this moment in time
luffy
isn't feeling great he's starving and
immensely fatigued as he also promised
he wouldn't eat anything unless it's
made by sanji in addition to that i
haven't touched on this that much in
this review because i wanted to focus on
the main plot thread specifically but
now seems like a good time to touch on
the b plot of this r quickly concerning
brook and pedro having decided to split
up to try to get their hands on the
podoglyph prince pedro finds himself
squaring off against tamago in this
fight we gain new insight into the last
time pedro came to whole cake island
with his partner
at this time he and his partner were
sentenced to
100 years however this means something
significantly different when it comes to
big mom as i'm sure all of you are now
aware of his partner had
30 years of his remaining lifespan
sucked from him causing him to die
leaving 70 remaining for pedro to square
off he comes during this time
begs big mom to spare him and shaves off
another 10 years
leaving 60 remaining in a final
last-ditch effort
pedro rips out his eye from the socket
and offers it up to big mom as partial
payment
big mom admires his efforts and shaves
off an additional 10 years before
sucking pedro of 50 years of his life
the conclusion to this tale
flashing forward to the present day
pedro doesn't intend on leaving this
island alive
he doesn't have much longer to live
anyway but he doesn't intend on dying in
this fight
this quick little flashback did a lot
for me in the way of getting pedro over
as a really intense and cool character
it's also at this point in the story
brook
much like pedro is faced with a
difficult decision and elects to
challenge big mom
head on which is one of the most ballsy
decisions made in this series
considering how powerful we understand
an emperor of the sea to actually be
and in addition to that chopper and
carrick rejoined the main plot of the
story using this new power of mirror
dimension wormholes they locate and
regroup with nami as well as pedro and
jimbei
however there's one small problem
i thought this scene was honestly really
funny and pretty character rich for
brooke
and big mom respectively there's not
really much to say about it other than
that it was a very funny scene and i
will talk more about brooke towards the
end of this video
right now i want to talk about a scene
that i think is a contender for being
one of the best scenes in the entire
series for me
at this pivotal point of the narrative
we understand that luffy has struggled
to get back to where he has said he
would be waiting for sanji
before collapsing we also know that
sanji is on route to this location to
find luffy also
but as sanji arrives in the area luffy
is
exceptionally difficult to locate amidst
against the bodies layering the streets
it's clear that a massive struggle took
place here for luffy to maintain this
position and that's when i was greeted
by one of the most striking panels
of this arc this is a point during this
chaotic story where everything
falls quiet as two best friends try to
reconnect and understand
each other better but moreover this is a
scene that once again
proves to us why luffy is the best fit
for a captain
in one piece and why he is their friend
first and foremost
willing to take himself to the cusp of
death in order to bring sanji back to
the light
and to convince him to accept their help
dotted throughout this scene are
callbacks to significant moments from
this arc
some i haven't even mentioned yet like a
specific flashback concerning sanji's
mother and her desire to rebel against
her abusive husband
wanting to not birth monsters she did
everything in her power to prevent it
and
sanji eventually ended up not being like
them and now that we have a causal
factor instead of pure happenstance
regarding sanji's difference between
himself and his brothers
it makes for a much more powerful scene
with luffy specifically during this
instance he offers this poor looking
food to ease
drawing a clear and intentional
comparison between him
and his mother when sanji as a child
prepared her food while she was ill
what's more is that luffy in this
instance
humbles himself greatly he drags himself
through hell and back
takes undeserved punishment from sanji
and still unfettered in his resolve
loves him and wants to help him in any
way he possibly can
however for sanji things aren't so clear
cut and it's here luffy is brought up to
speed on the three things keeping sanji
subservient to big mom number one he
struck his captain as hard as he could
which he views as unforgivable two his
father figures zeph in the east blue is
at a life-ending risk if sanji doesn't
go through with this
and three he doesn't want his family to
die no matter how horrible
most of them really are and to that
luffy has to say this
luffy refuses to take that and demands
of sanji to speak honestly about what he
wants and how
he really feels with that sanji's suave
and cool demeanor once again
crumbles wishing that he could go back
to the sunny but also can't abandon his
family but luffy
already knew this was what he wanted
because he knows the sort of person
sanji is he's lived with him he loves
him declaring that you've got us
let's go crash this wedding this scene
was phenomenally good captivating
heartfelt and passionately raw
and to be perfectly honest the entire
arc so far has hit its mark
and in many cases exceeded the mark
major plot points clashing like that one
i just spoke of already create this
engaging tear-jerking occasion but even
smaller things like pudding remarking
that sanji is a pathetic prince when
way back in alabasta sanji referred to
himself quite casually as
mr prince subtly small stuff like that i
find incredibly moving and serve to
create characters
like sanji who have an emotionally rich
core perfect for exploring in
exceptionally well written arcs like
this one
certainly for me this is the most
emotionally resonant arc in the post
time skip material so far and
i think at this point is my favorite
from that section also it's
impossibly good ending this section with
all the straw hat forces reconvening
only to reveal that despite being
cornered and captured
brooke still swiped all of the
pornoglyph prints from big mom's
possession
i laughed out loud reading that and
what's more it again serves to point out
that this arc is just tremendous fun
there's so much to enjoy in this and i
honestly cannot wait to jump back into
it again next week to figure out how
they're going to get out of this
how sanji will escape and how they're
going to overcome this wedding but
that will do it for this video as always
i've been totally not mark
i'll see you all next week when we take
on an emperor of the sea
and thank you so so much
[Music]
you